the show revolves around a lovable
teenager named Ayumi kohinara she is the
center of attraction at school due to
her good looks intelligence and
politeness one day her best friend
koshiro asks her out on a date Ayumi is
over the moon as she has secretly been
crushing on him for years that next day
as she is getting ready for the date a
news report on TV states that a red moon
will soon be visible however Ayumi who
is used to the phenomenon doesn't pay
much attention to it and leaves shortly
after she arrives at their meeting spot
and sees koshiro waiting for her but
before she can meet him suddenly she
gets a call from an unknown number
Ayumi nervously picks it up and finds
that it is one of her classmates named
zenko she reveals that she is going to
commit the unthinkable and asks sayumi
to turn around the latter obliges and
what she Witnesses shocks her to the
core zenko is actually sitting on the
edge of a tall building ready to end it
all at the same time the red moon also
appears Ayumi tries her best to convince
her classmate to get down but to no
avail a few hours later Ayumi awakens at
the hospital it is revealed that she
collapsed after seeing her classmate
commit the unthinkable she quickly asks
the nurse if senko survived to put the
nurse only stares at her in confusion
after a while Ayumi sees herself in the
mirror and becomes shocked somehow she
has turned into zanko believing that
everything is just a nightmare Ayumi
summons the doctor and asks him to fix
her but he simply replies that there's
nothing to be fixed right then zenko's
mother arrives and punishes her for
causing a ruckus after a while a
confused Ayumi gets discharged and she
has taken home the house is in complete
shambles which indicates that zanko has
been brought up in a very harsh
environment Ayumi also gets to know that
zenko's mother Miss umine is an arrogant
woman who only cares about herself she
is also abusive at times which explains
why zanko did what she did that night
Ayumi dreams if the good times she spent
with her best friends koshiro and kaga
ever since grade 2 they have always been
together and have had each other's backs
as Ayumi continues with her dream she
forgets all of her miseries and has a
sound sleep however the next morning her
happy world comes crashing down when she
realizes that she is still trapped
inside zanko's body despite this she
dresses up and rushes to a real home her
mother is watering the plants outside
and seeing her Ayumi breaks down in
tears she then hugs her mother but gets
pushed away immediately this makes Ayumi
realize that she cannot approach her
relatives anymore following this she
reluctantly heads to school and notices
kushiro waiting for her this lights up
ayumi's eyes and she deduces that her
boyfriend has somehow recognized her she
runs to him but koshiro walks right past
her and greets the fake Ayumi believing
that it is zenko she attacks her and
demands to have her body back however
her best friends koshiro and kaga
quickly separate her Ayumi tries to
explain her situation but they simply
ignore her and walk away left with no
choice Ayumi decides to head to class in
her new body but just after a few
periods she realizes how badly zenko is
tormented by her friends and teachers
alike they constantly bully her for
being overweight and also ignore her
existence in the evening Ayumi meets
koshiro alone in a room and reveals
everything to him but as expected he
doesn't believe any of it and leaves
devastated that her own boyfriend cannot
recognize her she runs to the rooftop
and starts crying right then she is
approached by zenko Ayumi begs her to
return her body but zenko simply laughs
she then reveals that she was tired of
being an outcast all of her life but now
that she has everything she wants she
will not let go of ayumi's body at any
cost before leaving zenko also reveals
that she is enjoying herself with her
new boyfriend koshiro after a while
asayumi breaks down again a small
parakeet approaches her it appears to be
completely calm despite being near a
human being the kind girl that she is
Ayumi brings it home assuming that
someone lost it she also prepares a
missing poster of the bird and pins it
to to a public notice board meanwhile it
is revealed that koshiro is not a saint
after all he pretends to like kaga but
in reality it is completely the opposite
koshiro is envious of his so-called best
friend because everyone gives kaga more
attention however kaga is oblivious to
all this he believes that koshiro is a
good man and always tries to help him it
is also revealed that kaga had a crush
on Ayumi but since koshiro approached
her first he could never confess his
true feelings later everyone in class is
preparing for an upcoming event being
the prettiest girl in class zenko is
asked to become the main attraction
which she gladly accepts all this is
being witnessed by a heartbroken Ayumi
but she can do nothing about it later as
she is painting something kaga
approaches her and they start talking
surprisingly unlike the other students
he doesn't bully her and talks with
genuine kindness he also makes fun of
her painting and fights with her because
of this Ayumi briefly forgets all of her
miseries after she leaves to get some
brushes kaga notices that her work is
very similar to that of ayumi's hence he
follows her to the classroom only to
learn that she is being bullied just
then kaga finds a piece of note written
by zenko and realizes that he has seen
it somewhere he quickly brings out his
notebook where Ayumi had written
something and compares the two sets of
handwriting lo and behold they are
exactly the same meanwhile through a
flashback we get to know that koshiro
had asked kaga to look after zenko as
she was claiming to be Ayumi in the
present kaga adds everything up and
finally learns that the real Ayumi is
trapped inside zenko's body hence
wasting no time he confronts the bullies
and tells them to stop when zenko
refuses kaga Whispers in her ear that he
knows the truth about her switch hearing
this zenko becomes scared that she will
be exposed for liking Nintendo so she
apologizes to Ayumi and leaves later
asayumi is heading home kaga calls her
by her real name and apologizes for not
realizing who she was sooner Ayumi who
was on the verge of disaster is over the
moon that someone finally recognizes her
with teary eyes she thanks him for being
a wonderful friend and with this the two
have an emotional moment but unbeknownst
to them koshiro is listening to their
conversation nearby he gets to know that
the girl he is dating is not Ayumi but
surprisingly he doesn't mind so long as
I get to touch those
in the next Scene It is revealed that
koshiro never liked Ayumi he just wanted
to date her as she was the prettiest and
most popular girl in school now that
zenko has switched bodies and is the
prettiest girl around he is content
dating her instead after kaga gets to
know of this he shouts at his best
friend for being selfish but koshiro
doesn't care Elsewhere on the rooftop
zenko also tells Ayumi the truth after
finding out that koshiro doesn't love
her anymore she becomes heartbroken and
starts running fortunately kaga catches
up to her and calms her down with a
tight hug he then promises to get back
her real self one way or another at
night as Ayumi is thinking about kaga
suddenly she gets a call from an unknown
number reluctantly she picks it up and a
woman speaks from the other end she
introduces herself as Uconn and asks
xyumi if she has switched bodies with
somebody the latter is perplexed and she
doesn't say a word so UConn arranges a
meeting at her place the following day
Ayumi and kaga go to the specified
location and meet Ukon who turns out to
be a researcher as requested Ayumi has
brought along the bird as the three
start discussing UConn reveals that she
has been studying the effects of the red
moon for quite some time now she got to
know of Ayumi because of the parakeet as
it only flies to those who have recently
switched bodies relieved that someone
finally knows of her condition
Ayumi asks if there's any way to reverse
the switch but UConn admits that there
isn't any in the past several people
have tried to do so but they have only
ended up dead hookah knows all of this
because she also accidentally switched
bodies many years ago when they tried to
switch back the other person died and
now she is stuck inside that person's
body later while the two best friends
are returning home Ayumi expresses her
displeasure over the fact that she will
never get her old life back to make
matters worse she comes across her house
and sees her parents living happily with
the Imposter heartbroken she prepares to
leave but just then kaga reveals that he
he loves her he also promises to be by
her side no matter what as expected
Ayumi is stunned by the sudden proposal
but before she can reply koshiro arrives
and drags her away since it's cold he
makes her wear his coat and asks if
everything is fine Ayumi who is going
through a roller coaster of emotions
reveals that there is practically no way
of returning to her original body as
soon as koshiro hears this his
expression changes and he walks away
with this Ayumi realizes that she too
cannot keep chasing someone else's
boyfriend hence she decides to get over
him after this she returns home and sees
xenko's mom ready to depart for her
night shift Ayumi genuinely feels bad
for her and decides to work on their
relationship on the other hand koshiro
carries out a detailed research on the
red moon phenomenon after hours of this
he finds several websites which show
step-by-step methods on how to switch
bodies in the morning the researcher
UConn wakes up and learns that the
parakeet bird has fled this means that
two new people are going to switch their
bodies in the upcoming red moon at
school some girls approach kaga and
curiously ask why a popular and handsome
guy like him is close to zenko without
any hesitation he reveals that he loves
her but asks the girls to keep it a
secret yeah right buddy however when he
enters the class it turns out that the
rumors between him and zanko have
already spread because of this the real
zenko becomes Furious as despite having
everything she is still not the center
of attention soon the classmates start
pinching ayumi's cheeks with affection
suzenko who is not able to Bear it
anymore storms out of the class she then
bumps into koshiro and reveals
everything about her past she was always
a chubby girl who no one liked the girls
bullied her and no guys wanted to date
her even her father left her one day
without so much as an explanation the
relationship between her and her mother
went downhill after that she would look
at Ayumi in the classroom jealous of the
fact that she had everything in life but
when no one was there for her koshiro
helped her clean after school and even
helped her with homework it was the
first time she was being seen by a guy
zenko instantly fell in love with him
but then Ayumi took him away as well she
could not bear the thought of losing
koshiro so she risked her life to switch
places with Ayumi hearing all this
koshiro sympathizes with her and
Promises to never leave her side he then
asks xenko's help in doing something
very drastic he wants to ruin Ayumi and
kaga's lives by switching their bodies
permanently zenko doesn't really
understand the notion of the plan but
nonetheless she is on board with it as
they discuss their evil plan the magical
parakeet listens in on their
conversation in the meantime Ayumi and
kaga are in a cafe at UConn's request
somehow the researchers found out about
koshiro's plan to switch them however
Ayumi does not believe that koshiro
could be so ruthless when the kids
refused to trust her UConn reveals that
the information was given to her by the
parakeet it turns out that the parakeet
used to be a human who accidentally
switched with a bird on a red moon day
however even after being told everything
Ayumi and kaga insist that koshiro is a
good person they have known him since
childhood and have grown up with them in
their eyes he can do no wrong especially
to the Friends he loves the most
elsewhere zenko brings koshira to a
temple where her father used to work she
reveals that he was a priest who is a
master of the body switching phenomenon
he had written a scroll which zenko
found after his death then using that
very scroll she risked her life and
ultimately changed into Ayumi koshiro
feels bad that she had to go through a
lot but assures her that they will get
rid of their Rivals very soon meanwhile
Ayumi keeps getting bullied at school
for her average looks up until a few
weeks ago she was treated like a queen
but after the switch she has finally
started realizing what zenko might have
been through since everyone is making
fun of her she registers that kaga must
have changed his mind and doesn't love
her anymore after school UConn
approaches zenko and asks her to come to
her house she wants to use the
information on the scroll for her
research although skeptical zenko agrees
to do it she is proud that she has
everything She Wants in life but UConn
taunts her by claiming that she still
doesn't look happy the comment hits home
for zenko because it is true she has
everything she ever wanted except for
happiness meanwhile as Ayumi and kaga
are walking back home she inquires why
he likes her even with an ugly face kaga
in turn answers that he is in love with
her kindness and her personality so it
doesn't matter to him if she is Ayumi or
zenko Ayumi smiles and feels a lot
better after the conversation the
following day the red moon is scheduled
to be seen koshiro and zenko are at the
rooftop discussing their evil plan with
an anxious look zenko asks if the plan
will really work to which koshiro
replies yes claiming he knows Ayumi
better than anyone this slightly upsets
zenko as despite koshiro being her
boyfriend he still knows more about
Ayumi than her in the next scene koshiro
approaches Ayumi and initiates his plan
firstly he apologizes for everything he
has done and then invites her to the art
room
Ayumi who still has feelings for him
gladly agrees unfortunately when she
reaches there she finds zenko waiting
for her on the other hand koshiro
approaches his former best friend kaga
and tells him to come to the balcony the
latter refuses but when koshiro
threatens to hurt Ayumi he agrees after
this the two head to the balcony where
koshiro reveals everything he explains
that he has always been jealous of
kaga's popularity among girls the body
switch may have ruined ayumi's life but
it got her closer to kaga koshiro cannot
stand that kaga has again got what he
wanted saying this he attempts to push
his best friend off the balcony into
struggle ensues in the background the
red moon is clearly visible meanwhile
all the girls who are in the art room
witness everything zenko tries to
manipulate Ayumi into seeing the fall
because if she does not kaga will simply
die but if she watches it they will
switch bodies however Ayumi is too smart
to fall for it and she slaps zenko for
her actions on the other hand the boys
are still tussling and at the end
koshiro manages to Chuck his friend from
the balcony but at the last second he
has also pulled because of which both of
them hit the concrete below the girls
immediately rushed to check up on them
and koshiro wakes up as if nothing ever
happened the scene then cuts to the
hospital where koshiro comes out of the
doctor's room and reveals that he is
actually kaga as both of them fell they
accidentally switched bodies with each
other zenko is heartbroken that she will
now have to date a different person
while Ayumi starts blaming herself for
the entire incident however now none of
them can do anything to reverse the
phenomenon the next day azukon is
researching the red moon she finds
something shocking it turns out that the
Moon's illumination is decreasing
rapidly meaning that the next red moon
may be the last one meanwhile at school
people notice the ugly girl Ayumi
getting close to koshiro oblivious to
the fact that he is actually kaga they
also assume that the two best friends
are fighting for Ayumi and hence she
becomes an overnight sensation now
everyone thinks that she is cute however
zenko is enraged that she is still not
the talk of the school after everything
that she has been through Ayumi is still
better than her she punches Amir in
anger and pushes her friends when they
ask her what is wrong later that day
koshiro finally gains Consciousness
zenko rushes to see him but doesn't feel
the same connection as his appearance
has changed koshiro asks her to be by
his side as he is still the same person
in heart at night while Ayumi is in her
room someone throws tiny pebbles at her
window scared she checks its side only
to find koshiro and kaga smiling it's
almost as if they have reconciled as
Ayumi stares in disbelief koshiro
finally reveals everything it turns out
that he is not a bad guy after all he
was just following the plan after he
learned about the body switch he made it
his mission to bring Ayumi back to
normal one way or another for this he
won zenko's trust and made her reveal
all of the body switching secrets in the
process he scarred his relationship with
his best friends but there was no other
choice hearing all of this and he later
Ayumi hugs the boys and thanks God for
giving her such wonderful friends
subsequently the three go out and have
some drinks like good old times there
kaga reveals that their balcony stunt
from yesterday was deliberate he further
explains that according to the scroll
they can interchange their bodies by
following a particular pattern this
pattern does not require the first two
people to be involved now with koshiro
and kaga interchanging the foundation
has already been laid but for the plan
to fully work zenko has to cooperate
with them the group does not want to
trick her even after everything she has
put them through this is because xenko
might possibly commit the unthinkable if
she finds out that koshiro never liked
the boys also agree and koshiro decides
to tell her the truth the next day kaga
even asks his friend to take his time
thinking that they have plenty of red
moon days left to carry out their
mission at home ayumi's relationship
with Miss umine is improving she helps
her around the house and takes care of
her when she can this reminds misuman of
the time that they were a happy family
unaware that Ayumi is not her daughter
she starts to like her again the next
morning kaga learns from the news that
the next red moon will be the last so he
rushes to school to stop koshiro from
admitting the truth to zenko because if
she refuses to cooperate they will not
have a second chance however it is too
late as koshiro has already told her the
entire truth zenko runs outside the
school crying at the Betrayal she
thought she had everything in life but
it all came down to koshiro rejecting
her kaga wants to look for her and
forcefully make her cooperate but the
other two are against it for some reason
they believe that deep down xenko is a
good person that evening it starts
raining heavily now the group only has a
few hours to find zenko as the red moon
phase is scheduled for the next day but
to their dismay they learned that zenko
has been missing since last night the
group immediately starts looking for her
around the town they check every
possible place that she might have gone
to but cannot find her anywhere
meanwhile xenko goes to UConn's house
and tells her of koshiro's plan to
exchange everyone's bodies for their
original ones UConn is impressed by the
elaborate pattern and claims that it
will surely work if tried she also
reveals that she was born into a poor
family and changed bodies with a girl
who was fed up with her wealthy parents
they soon realized that they were born
into their respective lives for a reason
but when they tried to exchange back the
other girl died hence UConn warns zenko
to correct her mistakes while she still
has the chance on the other hand an out
of sorts Ayumi returns home and asks
Miss Uma and if she remembers her
favorite place the latter who has now
started warming up to her daughter
replies that it is the Akatsuki jungle
wasting no time
Ayumi and the group rushed to the Jungle
they walked through the darkness until
they come across an abandoned research
lab inside zenko is seen crying in a
corner Ayumi tries to comfort her but
gets pushed to the ground just then miss
uman arrives at the scene it turns out
that she followed Ayumi to the jungle
and also overheard their conversation
with that saying a word she slaps zenko
for causing her friends so much trouble
she then orders her to apologize but
instead zenko brings out a pocket knife
fed up with all the bullying she runs to
the roof and threatens to commit the
unthinkable she also puts the knife on
her face and threatens to ruin ayumi's
Beauty but fortunately before she can do
something stupid Miss Suman runs to her
and hugs her tightly this is the first
hug the two have had in years
overwhelmed with all the love and
support zenko finally calms down and
misuman takes this opportunity to
apologize to her daughter she also vows
to do better from now on the next
morning during the red moon phase the
group goes through with koshiro's plan
they pair up kaga and Ayumi go first and
then zenko and koshiro fortunately the
plan works and the quartet finally
returns to their original bodies at last
Ayumi and zenko also put aside their
differences and become friends the movie
then skips to a month later Ayumi has
resumed her normal life where she is
happily living with her parents on the
other hand zenko and Miss umine have
also strengthened their bond meanwhile
UConn releases her parakeet bird and
sells her lab now she is ready to move
on from the red moon topic and do
something else with her life one day we
see the three best friends
Ayumi koshiro and kaga walking together
like the good old days they constantly
tease each other and have fun just then
Ayumi asserts that she can date neither
of the boys after what they have been
through however kaga brings her aside
and mentions that she should be with
koshiro as he was the one who sacrificed
the most to bring her body back Ayumi is
stunned by his selflessness and thanks
him for being so understanding she then
walks away and joins her boyfriend
koshiro kagazi thinks damn I should have
propositioned a three-way in the final
scene we see that zenko is now a popular
girl at school all thanks to ayumi's
exploits she herself has Started Loving
Her Body accepting her for who she is
the show ends as a proud kaga watches
her from nearby with a smile on his face
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching